the Marvel Studios black panther wakanda
forever purple carpet was incredible it
was all presented by our friends at
Lexus let's go ahead and take an
exclusive look by Lexus
[Applause]
this is crazy and amazing tonight it's
just all about the celebration of what
Black Panther in the world of wakanda
truly means to us all
I'm hanging out with the best fans in
the biz did we not tell you we were
gonna deliver on the outfits
becomes a very important moment for the
filmmakers and for the artists and the
crew and the fans
[Music]
to be back we are here we've not Angela
Vasa who plays Queen Ramona hello
hello Marvel World
being a female genius especially for me
um it's really cool in the finale here
of phase four looking at it by phases we
meet an entire New Kingdom the king that
King is here thank you guys I love it
Neymar look he's one of the most classic
Marvel characters in publishing he's
somebody that we've wanted to introduce
for a long time and you want to
introduce this person in the right way
Neymar is probably one of our oldest
characters yeah I think he first
appeared in 1939 as a Submariner so to
bring him finally to the screen is such
a big deal they asked me if I if I know
how to swim and I said I never drunk
before
which is true really excited about about
what we were able to do we worked with a
lot of different cultural Consultants
were able to cast some incredible actors
and just the physical of it you know
getting into the water and doing it for
real it was fantastic Mr Riri Williams
she is indeed coming in hot I got the
car and I was like
I called my mom straight to voicemail I
call my girlfriend she didn't answer
they're doing it again
they are so ready for it
she's coming with a lot of voice with a
lot of passion about what means a lot to
her about wanting to protect her people
about proving to the world that she is
worthy that she too is capable of great
things we always say that it's part of
our growth and our Global success is to
have everyone All Eyes watching so all
eyes watching means that we can
represent most and we will continue to
do that
[Music]
but what keeps her going I think the
love of country and love of her people
and she really believes in the power of
humanity together and I think she brings
that to her work
this one as everyone can imagine is is
very emotional it's very loaded what
makes it so different obviously is the
passing of Chadwick and I think the film
has the perfect balance of of honoring
his legacy and a feeling of optimism for
the future how do you move on when you
feel like you can't you know how do you
move on in the face of immeasurable odds
how do you move on when your heart is
broken no matter what challenges or
adversity comes goodness will prevail
well you know we are a passionate people
indeed and uh we indeed brought it and
of course our beloved brother made his
transition and we just loved him and he
was such an example of excellence and
wisdom for us that we wanted to step
into those shoes at the end of the day
we made something really special we knew
that this time yeah there's no mistaking
it the characters the world that we know
and love just teaming up again
with purpose with meaning with love
it meant the world to us to to reunite
and to bring this film to you